hey guys Mary here at PAX Prime 2015 and
we are working with the mix to bring you
guys some sweet indie games that I just
found out about I want you guys to know
about them too
I'm talking to Justin from ASCII soft
how's it going good
alright yeah you're gonna show me a game
that I saw trailer for and I said that
looks like a sweet really really gross
vivid beat em up game from the 80s it's
covered in blood one hits it's really
really aggressive and that's what I love
about it so much people are kind of
saying looks a little bit like a
side-scrolling hotline Miami
this is katana zero alright so I guess
I'll hop right into this you were gonna
hop right in I think people will
probably make those comparisons when you
start seeing the action of it because
it's the mechanics that are just so
vivid and real and it's quite violent in
the best way possible yeah definitely
the whole thing has sort of a um yeah as
you already said it's a real 80s vibe
it's a neo noir game so there's a lot of
real glowing lights which you'll see in
a second right now you're kind of
learning the basics of jumping mechanics
um just came over the tutorial here
there's a lot of expository dialogue but
I don't have time for expository yeah
exactly luckily I have the the option to
interrupt people now there's not too
much that we're learning about the story
yet but there's there's some elements to
it that you'll learn about later on as
you go through forth yeah a little bit
more about like what you're doing and
why you're murdering all these people
yeah essentially the idea is in every
level sorry it is hard to talk and play
this difficult game at the same time but
um every level you're sort of planning
out your course of action instead of
actually doing it which is why when you
fail you're like no that plan won't
really work let me think of something
else and for that exact same reason I
can the character can focus hard and
actually slow down time and Const
trait on certain points okay by the
meter in the upper middle of the screen
yes and so now that you've already
figured out a plan that would work well
this is you actually going out and
getting the plan yeah including all the
slow-mo parts in real time and this is
sort of a security tape so you can fast
road you can rewind it's just a nice
little treat to have at the end of the
level after doing some cool stuff its
stylized in a great way that lets you
kind of enjoy what you just did I think
one of the best parts yeah is that
really nice satisfaction feeling at the
end when you've executed something that
probably took you a hundred tries to get
right at something now you you're quite
familiar with these levels but a lot of
these people it's the kind of thing all
right so you can smash bullets back yeah
you can do that too this is the kind of
thing that you're gonna have to die in
order to understand what to do next time
alright so here's a level with them
slightly more interesting mechanics
because all these enemies are gun
wielders as you kind of saw last level I
can slash bullets back and that does
become a necessity in levels like this
where there's just a hail fire or a
bullets coming at you at all times
but it is very punishing and if you lose
concentration for a second then you're
gonna have to start over right so even
someone who's been playing this for
really long time easily connects hugs
playing this a lot but that's fine right
and kind of again similarly a hotline
Miami like it's okay I enjoy failing
multiple times because you can try
different routes and there's different
routes that can succeed as well so this
one won't we know might work for this
route but you might play it again and
try something completely different and
still succeed so it's kind of cool it
gets a lot of replayability when you do
that yeah I try to strike a good balance
between having a real improvisational
feel where you don't really know what to
do but you have a set of acrobatic
tactics to help you along the way and at
the same time just have a really
fast-paced action game your animations
are pretty tight like they look what I
would expect out of a ninja with the
arms behind you when you're running
there's a lot of really good animations
that you do and you're swiping your
katana and other things it looks like
you put a lot of efforts into the
animation style make look everything
real smooth oh yeah well I actually
didn't do the animation I'm not very
artistically motivated Michael Lambert
did a lot of the animation right now and
he's one of the main artists behind
Binding of Isaac rebirth so that's cool
to have him on the team so here I'm just
gonna show you this little ending
cutscene so as you can see there's
dialogue choices you can interrupt
people you can talk to them it's very
based on The Walking Dead telltale game
sort of okay but that's actually the end
of the demo so well that works out
really well good so thank you so much
for showing me that Justin so that was
katana zero and when can people expect
to find this 2016 2016 alright well
thank you guys for watching that was
katana zero and for the latest on all
indie games be sure to stay tuned to
games.com